all right all right we appreciate this
weekend and this weather oh my gosh is
it absolutely glorious out there and it
feels so good because the air has been
drying out with all of that southwest
breeze that we had yesterday
now it's not so pretty up north with the
world of smoke forecast we do appreciate
that we're not going to have much of it
in our air maybe a little haze at times
you can see how nice and blue southern
nevada is while all that orange red and
purple all of that smoke continues to
circulate up north up around reno lake
tahoe northern california where the
fires continue to burn let's check
valley temperatures feels good outside
lots of 70s humidity levels in the teens
this morning and dew points in the 20s
that's just telling us the air is a lot
lot drier so drying out and heating up
into the weekend please make some cool
plans make sure you've got lots of cool
water around if you're letting the kids
dive into the pool if you're having a
barbecue and just make sure you've got
the sunscreen too we're going to be near
record highs like closer to record highs
than normal highs as we get into the
holiday weekend especially monday and
into tuesday showers and thunderstorms
traveling through the plains to the
upper midwest and the northeast
more than 15 inches of rain now that's
been added up along with tornadoes check
out some of the flooding
this is bridge bridgewater township wow
this is their double a ballpark ball
stadium their
their minor league for the yankees i
think it's the somerset patriots it's td
bank ballpark in bridgewater township
underwater i mean it's kind of living up
to the name of bridgewater it's terrible
all the flooding there they still have
rivers at at flood to moderate stages
they're flooding there so there's so
many cars there were cars that were just
completely submerged in all this
flooding it's going to be a while before
these waters recede it'll probably take
the next several days before they can
even see this the field again at this
ballpark the flooding has just been
tremendous and again 44 people killed in
all of ida's wrath from the coast of
louisiana all the way to the northeast
dry and breezy for us i don't think the
winds will be as strong as they've been
recently
but up at mount charleston we are
looking for maybe 20 25 mile an hour
winds upper 70s at kyle canyon even
cooler at lee canyon where they're
having all the summer fun again this
weekend today through sunday 101 out at
the lake please be careful life jackets
ah you just can't go without them 99
degrees for the valley today and then we
just see the numbers keep going up 101
tomorrow 104 satur sunday 106 on monday
oh my gosh that's a lot of heat for the
unofficial end of summer and we'll see
those temps trend down a little bit as
we get into next week have a safe
weekend everybody